MICHAEL WARE (VOICEOVER):
In Olympic boxing,
Cuba is a heavyweight.
The nation's pride often rests
upon success in the ring.
Oh, my god.
MICHAEL WARE (VOICEOVER): And
few have known as much success
as the man who has
just walked in.
What an honor to meet me.
Ah.
[laughs]
MICHAEL WARE (VOICEOVER): Felix
Savon is a living legend, one
of the world's greatest
amateur boxers,
three-time Olympic
gold medalist,
six-time world champion.
But Savon has been more than
just a champion in the ring.
He has been the face of
Fidel Castro's revolution.
Time and time again, he rejected
multimillion dollar offers
to turn professional.
It said he'd turned down $25
million to fight Mike Tyson.
And he did it, he says,
because he believes
that much in the revolution.
I know I'm supposed to be a
journalist here and objective,
but I'm such a fan.
Yes, I was there.
It was a great victory.
Tell the champ I don't
know if he drinks or not,
but I'd like to have a
little drink with him.
[speaking spanish]
Si.
All right, let's go.
[speaking spanish]
MICHAEL WARE: Please, Champ.
Salud.
Ah, y victoria.
And victory.
To victory.
Why didn't you take the
money and go professional?
[speaking spanish]
Really?
Ah, si.
[speaking spanish]
A hut.
A hut is better.
Uh-huh.
What?
-Yeah.
-No.
That's what he said.
Yeah.
He went from a
hut with a candle
to being the face of his nation
and the face of a revolution.
INTERPRETER: Yes, sir.
Did that help shape his
view of the revolution?
[speaking spanish]
Ta.
Yeah?
Wow.
[speaking spanish]
So he was the front line of
the revolution with his fists.
[speaking spanish]
Yeah?
Yeah.
[speaking spanish]
Right.
So there'll be an evolution.
MICHAEL WARE
(VOICEOVER): Felix Savon
is a face of the revolution,
a nationalist, and a loyalist.